hi my name is vivian barry
and i am the lab manager of the
pathobiology team
at gilead sciences in california and
today
i'm happy to present a slide deck that i
put together that talks about the
principles
of effective method development in
pathobiology research
so here's an outline of what i'm going
to be covering
i'll say a little bit of what the
pathobiology team
does at gilead and the research that we
supply
and then i'm going to go into several
examples
of using in situ hybridization assays on
various projects this is a very exciting
assay that we like to use along with ihc
and it's been very impactful for a lot
of projects
the first example i'm going to talk
about is using a dual
in cq hybridization and ihc essay
and i'll walk you through how we were
able to identify as
a subset of b cells in particular
b regs that's a very hot topic
in tumor biology and
the second example will be um how we
used uh dual
and feature hybridization assays and i
actually have three
minor examples showing how it was
impactful in finding a subset of
macrophages that expressed a specific
mrna
species there were no suitable
antibodies available for that protein so
i'll show you how we got around that
and second example will be identifying a
subset of cd4 positive t
cells and the third example will be
identifying a subset of cd8 positive t
cells so um quite interesting and
different
projects and how this has been very
impactful and then last i'd like to end
with showing how
we use standard and c2 hybridization
assays along with our ihc
in in times where we were not able to
have
antibodies that were available we didn't
have any robust
antibodies for a good reagent for ihc
and also we were able to identify
proteins that have poor retention in
ffpe so i'll show a couple examples of
that
so first i want to talk about the
overview of what we do
at gilead we do many many things but i
kind of uh summarize it into three
important
main tasks that we do the first
is target validation and human diseases
now anyone in the pharmaceutical
industry knows that this
is a critical step in drug development
we analyze human tissues to validate
disease targets
that will in turn support many decisions
such as a go
or no go for our therapeutic programs at
gilead
target validation can help in finding
better biomarkers in disease
it can help predict and measure disease
progression
and aid with patient stratification so
that's the first and foremost thing that
we do within my team
the second thing we do is characterize
and validate
animal models research has
researchers have assessed uh new
therapies
mechanism of actions of therapeutics and
animal models
before assessing them in human subjects
so this has been going on
many people are aware of this but
obviously all animal studies can't be
a direct relation to the human
indication of interest
so characterizing and validating these
ammo models is essential to confirm that
the animal model depicts
similar pathology to the human disease
and obviously a well-characterized
animal model can help
predict the response in humans so it's
very important to validate these targets
in the individual model before moving on
to human tissues
the third and last component of our work
in the pathobiology lab
is evaluating drug effects or we like to
call it the moa the mechanism of action
in models of disease
so animal studies can provide evidence
of the effectiveness of a drug
we can accept we can assess if a
therapeutic antibody or small molecule
shows
efficacy using these animal studies so
they help
understand pathophysiological mechanisms
of the drugs
we can determine whether it's toxic or
if there's efficacy
and lastly the data on the kinetics and
pd
markers or pharmacodynamic markers and
animals can help
aid in the selection of effective doses
in the animal
models and also going into human
indications
so the first example of a method we've
used in my lab
is the dual staining with
immunohistochemistry and chromogenic and
c2 hybridization which i call
fish it might be pronounced kish but i
pronounce it
fish just so on the next slide you'll
see what i talk about
we use a dual ihc and fish to detect a
subset of b
cells that express a specific secreted
cytokine
now the b cell sub population i'm
referring to are the b
regs they're now highly studied when
looking at the suppressive role in the
immune system and cancer and it's a
hot topic definitely nowadays
you don't just hear about t-regs anymore
you hear about the b-rex
detecting cytokines with
immunohistochemistry can be limiting
cytokines are poorly quantitative
and actually they're very hard to detect
since they are secreted proteins and
that's been a
ongoing theme in my lab when trying to
detect
any secreted protein or secreted matrix
enzymes
so we need to find a way to detect the
localization of the cytokine of interest
so what we did was um identify
secreted cytokine c by detecting the
mrna
by in c2 hybridization commercial
antibodies i say here that they're not
available for ihd they actually were
available
but they weren't specific they were
really hard to detect this depleted
cytokine
so on the same slide we wanted to follow
with ihc using a
membrane marker cd19 to identify b cells
and so what we were hoping for in which
what we did get was that we were able to
identify
a subset of b cells so they were cd19
positive that also express
mrna of cytokine c and i'll show you on
the next slide but
what this was very helpful for us is
that we were able to understand
if these cell types played a role in
cancer these b regs in particular
we understood the population of these
cell types and various human cancer
tissues
and we were able to visualize the
expression in spatial relation to
specific cells within the tissue
landscape so um
we use the human tissue lymphoma as our
positive control
and for method development for ihc
and fish dual assay and so
first the singleplex i see that you see
here
showed nice and expected membranous
staining of the b cell population in the
lymphoma tissue lymphoma is filled with
b cells so we use
that's why we use this as a positive
control
then the single plex fish
showed the cells that were positive for
the mrna of cytokine c
so we had to optimize these conditions
as singleplexes first
before we're able to combine and make it
into a dual ihc and c2 hybridization
assay and what we did
we did the dual ihc we could identify
the b reg cells
there that were of interest to our
studies and it was also a great way to
help us
understand if these b cells were present
in specific tumor types
in many different human cancers so that
was a very important assay that we
developed
in the lab now everything is automated
so it's much easier but this is a great
way to get around
when you don't have any antibodies
available to produce a robust
assay so
the next example i'm going to show you
is how we utilized
a 2-plex in c2 hybridization to detect
two mrna species and how they helped
help excuse me how they helped confirm
data in our projects
in my first example um i'm going to show
how we identify the coexpression of a
protein
and a macrophage marker by using the
commonly used macrophage
marker that everyone knows is cd68 we
knew that protein a was expressed by
macrophages this was done
through orthogonal methods so it was
confirmed through rtpcr
western blot analysis but we were never
able to visualize
what subset of macrophage if it was a
subset or if it was all macrophages
if there were any that expressed protein
a
we tried to find appropriate commercial
antibodies for protein a
but they were not able we weren't we
weren't able to find good reagents
and so we were desperate to understand
where protein a was expressed we knew it
was in macrophages we didn't know where
and i'll show the images on the next
slide but you you'll see again that
we're able to identify key
subsets of macro stages that were
expressing protein a
and again it helped redefine our
understanding of the location of protein
and the tissue
so here um i'm showing that we used um
ulcerative colitis for our two plex
and c2 hybridization assay we always run
pdib which is on the bottom left hand
panel um this this specific pro pvib
detects
ubiquitin b and we also have our
negative control on the bottom right
hand panel
that detects mrna of a species of
bacteria so that should not be detected
in the human tissue on the top panel
you see protein a's single in situ
hybridization assay
on ulcerative colitis as you know
alterative colitis is
a very inflamed tissue and
here i have a zoomed in image of that
just showing you have that
dotted line showing the border between
the colonic epithelium
and the lamina propria below and here's
a zoomed in image of that where you see
that
protein a is detected in the immune
cells below that
green dotted line in the lamina propria
and also
in the colonic epithelia on top of that
green dotted line
we wanted to understand what immune
cells
um what immune related cells were
positive for protein a
so we did a dual in seizure
hybridization to detect
the protein a and first on the left you
can see
cd68 ihd stating
if you have experience with colonic
tissue most people will know that the
colonic epithelia can be sticky
but if you look at the macrophages that
are located below the colonic epithelia
that's what we want to focus on
this marker is detecting the macrophages
in the lamina propria
so there are many macrophages found in
ulcerative colitis when you look at the
ihc
on the right panel you see protein a's
mrna detection by in c3 hybridization
when we performed the dual in situ
hybridization assay
on the ulcerative colitis tissue we
could then visually see this
co-expression
of protein a's mrna and cd68 mrna
i'm going to zoom in so that you can see
that
and i have an arrow showing a macrophage
with protein a
mrna so what was very interesting about
this result is that we found that
only the macrophages found near the
lumen of the colonic tissue were
expressing protein a
mrna so this was truly a new discovery
um not all the macrophages were
expressing protein a as we thought
before and it really was a subset of
macrophages that
were able to visualize for the first
time
looking at the tissue architecture
so my next example is
[Music]
an example of using two plex in feature
hybridization to detect two rna species
when we looked when we were looking for
a subset of cd4 positive t
cells uh fox b3 positive cells that are
expressing a specific
chemokine receptor so a little
background on the study
the specific t cells comprise a really
low percentage of the population i think
we're looking
at about three to five percent of the
total cd4 positive cells found in human
tissues
and we were expecting an increase when
looking at diseased tissues and we
wanted to be able to detect this
ihc regions were available to test we
actually did have a nice robust
ihc assay we but we wanted to know if it
was real staining
because if we're looking at a three to
five percent population of cd4 positive
t
cells we wanted to be sure that we were
looking um
or or that we were getting the results
that were true and specific
so in this case we wanted to
identify that the robust ic reagent was
truly specific
and that it will also detect a chemokine
which we're going to call chemokine r
expressed in a subset of fox p3 positive
t
cells so here i have head and neck
cancer
and you see fox p3 ihc on the right
panel
and what we wanted to do was in that
population
determine if any of those were fox p3
and chemokine are positive so again
we're looking at a population that's
comprised of three to five percent of
all
um the cd uh cd4 positive cells and so
uh what what we determined is that if
you look at
box p3 in teal and chemokine are in red
there was a subpopulation of those fox
p3 positive cells
that we could detect the chemokine rmrna
here's another example another head and
neck
cancer tissue where we were able to
identify a few double positive cells
again using um teal for fox p3
and chemokine r in red and so
where the arrows are pointing is the
subpopulation of cells
that were expressing chemokine are
and again with all our controls we with
all our
assays we have controls on the left we
have our positive controls
and on the right we have our dat b
negative controls for the dual
ihc assays
so my third example is to identify
a subset of cd8 positive t cells
expressing a specific chemokine
receptors so as you can see there's a
a pattern here chemokines are secreted
we can't
really detect them well with ihc
reagents so that's why we went
to use chromogenic and c2 hybridization
and this study on the background is that
we were looking at chronic hpv viral
infection in chimpanzees
um we obviously don't do any research in
chimpanzees anymore so please note that
these
ffpe blocks were quite old
and we were still able to identify what
we needed to identify
using these blocks and also using the
two plex
in situ hybridization so we wanted to
examine if this
specific subset of population of cells
contributed to
the viral replication when you have a
chronic infection
so we ran the dual in situ hybridization
um in our control tissue which we used
was the cortex of the human lymph nodes
uh we wanted to make sure it worked in
the human tissues before you ran it on
the chimp tissues which i mentioned
were many years um were processed many
years ago
so we were able to identify um a few
double positive cells
these um cytotoxic subset of cytotoxic t
cells were identified
um in the dark brown are the cd8
positive t
cells and then where you see red is
a dual expression of cd8 and the
chemokine receptor
so we were able to examine if this
specific population of cells
were affecting chronically infected
chimpanzees
with hpv and so we were able to apply
this onto the
chimp tissues
so i want to get into other everyday
applications
that we like to use in cg hybridization
just standard fish assays no dual assays
or anything like that and we basically
use them
almost on a weekly basis to validate
antibodies
validate our reagents and we also use
them to identify proteins that either
have poor retention in ffpe
or where there's no antibody available
to use for
ihd purposes so i want to
talk about protein x protein x is a
secreted matrix enzyme
um and we knew it was highly expressed
in colorectal carcinomas
and so typically when you do ihc work
you work with
ffpe blocks and so on the left
we have protein x ihc
and if one were to look at this you
would think well it's not that highly
expressed in this colorectal carcinoma
tissue
it kind of looks like a murky stain
maybe even non-specific staining
but this puzzled us because we knew that
protein x was highly expressed
in colorectal carcinoma so what
we did was we looked at the fresh frozen
component of this tissue
this is not a cereal section but i will
show you a few in the next couple slides
um then we got this result on the right
where we stained
protein x antibody on fresh frozen
colorectal carcinoma tissue a very very
different
staining pattern that you see here we
see a lot of staining in the stroma
and no staining in the tumor cells and
we wanted to know is this
specific is this correct and so the way
we were able to answer that question
is we if you look on the left there's
ihc
on fresh rails and tissues and on the
right we did in situ hybridization
on the fresh frozen tissues the s stands
for stroma
so just as we saw these are cereal
sections we were able to detect the mrna
of protein x in the stroma and little to
none
on the tumor cells i think i have a
zoomed in image here showing that these
were actually
activated fibroblasts that were making
um protein x and it was actually
secreted
into the stromal component of the tissue
whereas this tumor the tumor cells are
almost completely negative
here's the example i showed two slides
ago on the left was the ihc
and on the right is in situ
hybridization so
again we were able to detect the stromal
cells
these are activated fibroblasts that's
where the arrows pointing to
and in this case we saw that some tumor
cells were slightly positive so
that blushy stain that you see on the
left with the ffpe
sample those are that that really was a
true stain it wasn't stickiness
but we couldn't confirm it until we saw
the mrna
being detected uh by by using in c2
hybridization
so this is a close-up again showing the
activated fibroblasts within that narrow
stroma
the tumor cells close to that lumen
where the l is
those are slightly positive so what you
see on the left with ffpe
is a true signal and we knew that we
were able to that we were actually
detecting
protein x by by confirming through in c2
hybridization
i like to show this picture because one
thing about protein x that
we know is that um it's
secreted produced and secreted by
activated fibroblasts
and these fibroblasts are activated more
closely to the tumor
stromal boundaries so i have that
depicted there by
t colon s we see the tumor cells
with the t and then we see the ts tumor
stromal boundary
and if you were to look at an ffp image
which is on the left
with ihc it again looks like a very
sticky blushy stain
but when we did in situ hybridization we
were able to confirm that
that is true expression of protein x
at that tumor stromal boundary
so lastly i like to show this example as
well
where we had a really nice working
uh robust ihc assay for protein z
and it worked very well in ffpe samples
the only problem and i don't want to say
it was a problem but we didn't know this
at the time
is that we truly thought protein z was
expressed only by
immune related cells so we saw
big reservoirs and macrophages
neutrophils
we never detected it in tumor epithelium
until we stain lung squamous cell
carcinoma which is the example i have
here
so we saw this very strong staining in
the tumor cell epithelia
and we thought we need to confirm this
ihc because
up until this point we've only seen it
in immune relate itself
and so we did do this feature
hybridization
and lo and behold we were able to detect
kind of a mirror image of what we saw
with the ihc
when you look at serial sections and i
have a zoomed in image here
um this was really nice to show that for
the first time
we discovered that protein z was
actually being made by the tumor
epithelia and not just by macrophages or
neutrophils
this is what we normally saw with
protein z and the top
right hand panel where you see the ihc
protein z was found in macrophages
here we have tumor-associated
macrophages surrounding this tumor
island
and on the left we have the in situ
hybridization confirming that these
macrophages or
tams are truly our reservoirs of protein
z
and again we have our positive control
on the bottom left
and our negative control on the bottom
right
so this is the last part of my
presentation um
i just want to talk about you know
throughout this talk we've talked about
antibody validation specificity
and we you know with the validation
steps that we do
we we include orthogonal methods always
um if
possible we'd like western blot analysis
if westerns aren't available
facts is always good for surface
proteins elisa's
and in feature hybridization of course
and what we do is we usually start with
cell pellets
we like cell pellets because you can use
them as control reagents
you can over express you could do
knockout cell pellets
we work with a lot of phosphatase
specific antibodies
and so we're able to treat with
phosphatase treatment to verify target
fossil specificity with cell pellets
so these are definitely reagents that we
like to use and have
when we do our antibody validation
so the way we go about it and this is
this was for a prostate target
we'll call it prostate target x we make
a cell micro
array we call them cmas not really tmas
they're not tissues so we call them cmas
cell microarrays
and here we have an example of 10
different
cell types um they all range in in
either being negative
um expression for for prostate target x
or a medium expression or high
and here it was nice when we worked with
the scientists we were able to have
an orthogonal method to compare uh when
we validate our reagents this is
facts analysis of protein x and
um you can see that there are actually
three cell types that are positive
for protein x and then you have six
other cell types that are negative
and the positivity did range from low
medium and high so it's really nice to
get that range of expression
in order to do validation of your of
your reagents
so when we tested several antibodies we
found the best one was this monoclonal
antibody
that seemed to adequate adequately label
the cell pellets
you can see the facts data in the bottom
right hand corner of each panel
but the three positive cell types or
cell lines
that were deemed positive by facts also
checked out through ihc
um this is this is a pretty clear
um go or no-go decision but since then
we've always incorporated in c2
hybridization
so we went ahead and did the mrna
expression analysis
by fish on these cell pellets and
what was comforting and pleasing to see
was that the fish data corroborated with
the ihc data that was produced
which also corroborated with the facts
data
so in summary um i hope i was able to
convince you that
using chromogenic and c2 hybridization
is a
powerful technique to localize
mrna within fixed or fresh frozen
tissues one thing i didn't mention but
it's worth mentioning now is
when you use chromogenic and feature
hybridization and not fluorescence
although fluorophores are much more
stable nowadays
all you need for fish is light
microscopy so these flies are archivable
you never lose their signal and i've
stained slides from seven ten years ago
and they're still bright with the
chromogenic and feature hybridization
signals
using fish or dual fish or dual
ihc and fish it really allows you to
determine
exact cell types involved not only does
it help you
identify cell types but also subtypes of
specific cells
we've used them as an adjunct to ic
assays confirming ambiguous ihc results
or also confirming expression when we
don't have
a good iec reagent the data can be
generated from both fresh frozen or ffpe
tissues where i showed you
and in the example where we had that
secreted
enzyme within the matrix the ihc
only worked in fresh frozen and not in
ffpe so we were able to
make sure that that was a true signal
and we use this technique to validate
reagents for ihc
method development now it's kind of like
one of the steps that we
um it's one of the check marks that we
have to check when we do antibody
validation
and so using all these methods have
provided valuable
and new insights to many programs at
gilead
and so um it's always good to have
orthogonal methods
but um just being able to
incorporate different assays to
determine specific
specificity is our number one goal
within the lab
so i'd like to acknowledge um the folks
in the non-clinical safety and
pathobiology group
chris clark and laurie deal who are my
managers and rosanna
and alison who are instrumental in
getting a lot of these assays up and
running
amanda nichols vigdell was involved with
a lot of the studies
that i discussed today and there are
many folks at
acd advanced cell diagnostics that have
helped chris bunker
lee shang shilban ruby and the rest of
the acd support team
um and the folks at roche and ventana
without them we wouldn't be able to
get these essays up and running so judy
wendy adrian and
kelly i appreciate their help and
support